if you're in the northern hemisphere
it's that time of year when you start to
Get Cozy pull those sweaters out of the
closet sip your pumpkin spice lattes and
stare out the window waiting for the
leaves to start turning orange well over
at microcosmos.store we have the perfect
companion for this time of year and that
is our journey to the micro Cosmos
sweatshirt it's soft it's cozy and it
confirms to those around you that you
are in fact human and speaking of that
pumpkin spice latte we sell a lovely
tardigrade mug that is perfect for your
warm beverage of choice or if you've got
2 billion tardigrades that you need to
re-home so check out
microcosmos.store where you can find our
sweatshirt mug and even our very own
microcosmos microscope
thank you
James our master of microscopes is
always on the hunt for rare ciliates
that live in areas low in oxygen but
when he gathers those samples and puts
them under a growth light his tubes
quickly turn the color of the green
sulfur bacteria that thrive in those
anaerobic conditions these organisms are
not particularly hard to come by
especially if you know the kinds of
environments that meet their basic needs
but they can still manage to surprise us
like in 2005 when scientists reported
that they had found green sulfur
bacteria living in a place that seemed
impossible for them to survive in
a hydrothermal vent
[Music]
now it doesn't sound particularly
comfortable to me but life around a
hydrothermal vent is not impossible
these structures tend to form in places
where tectonic plates are shifting away
from each other creating cracks that
heated water from under the crust can
then erupt through and despite the
incredible heat within the vent and the
lack of light around it there is life
an ecosystem built in part on bacteria
that are able to turn chemicals from the
vent into food these bacteria do not
need sunlight to feed themselves and the
organisms that surround them but green
sulfur bacteria are not like those
chemosynthetic residents that we know to
expect in hydrothermal vents green
sulfur bacteria rely entirely on
photosynthesis for their food needs
which means they need light now to
understand the secrets Behind the Green
silver bacteria's deep sea Survival
Let's Start by talking about what a
green sulfur bacteria even is
these bacteria are known more formally
as the family chlorobiathe and their
distinguishing feature is that they
abhor oxygen to power their
photosynthesis they rely on reduced
sulfur instead which means that green
silver bacteria prefer to live in areas
of water deep enough to favor sulfur
over oxygen but still allow enough light
for the bacteria to create their food
most green sulfur species cannot swim
which is why they're so still in our
footage there are a few species that
have vacuoles that can fill or release
gas to help them move up or down the
water column but overall they're not
really movers and you also may have
noticed that not all of the bacteria in
our footage is green and that some of
them are in fact purple at times they're
quite a contrast to the green sulfur
bacteria not just because of their color
but because they are able to swim around
these purple neighbors do share one
common trait with green silver bacteria
though they also use sulfur to carry out
photosynthesis and so they are known as
wait for it purple sulfur bacteria we
would call this an unclear creative
ripoff but they were actually described
about a century before their green
counterparts as a family the purple
sulfur bacteria are known as Chromo TSE
which does feel a bit more distinct as
far as names go while the chemical
reactions underpinning their
photosynthesis are not identical purple
and green silver bacteria have similar
requirements for where they live to make
that photo so this has happened they
need light and they need sulfur so it
isn't strange to find both organisms
living on our slides together but that
doesn't do their proximity enough
Justice these two bacteria don't just
tend to show up in the same areas of
water green sulfur bacteria like to live
under purple sulfur bacteria providing
sulfur to their purple upstairs
neighbors in exchange the purple sulfur
bacteria Shield the green sulfur
bacteria from oxygen but of course life
isn't necessarily easy just because
you've buried yourself away from
anything vaguely threatening the green
sulfur bacteria still has to be able to
survive underneath its chromody accee
comforter it helps that green sulfur
bacteria have a larger affinity for
hydrogen sulfide ensuring they still get
the chemicals they need to power their
reactions but they still need light and
for that they rely on a powerful
organelle called the chlorosome
the chlorosome is unique to Green sulfur
bacteria and its entire purpose is to
help the bacteria get light it's the
shape of an oval and stuck to the inside
of the plasma membrane and inside the
chlorosome there are around a hundred
thousand of the green silver bacteria's
photosynthetic pigments those pigments
are compounds that aggregate together
creating the largest known light
harvesting complex in nature and this
Arrangement is different from other
familiar complexes where the pigment
compounds are arranged with proteins and
in much smaller numbers in green silver
bacteria the interactions between these
pigments make the bacteria very
efficient at Gathering light and then
transferring that energy to a protein
called the Phenom Matthews Olsen protein
which will help carry the energy to the
areas of the cell that need it for
photosynthesis so that even when they're
in the dark the green sulfur back Serie
A can get what they need to survive
of course sometimes your surroundings
are dark because you're covered in
purple sulfur bacteria and sometimes
they are dark because you are in a
hydrothermal vent and for the scientists
behind the 2005 paper we mentioned at
the beginning of the episode The
chlorosome would end up being a very
useful organelle to know about
they had gone to the East Pacific Rise
Gathering samples from plumes above the
vents and in their samples they found a
small green non-motile phototrophic
sulfur bacteria it looked a lot like
green sulfur bacteria
The Firm that it actually was a species
of green silver bacteria they looked for
that phena Matthews Olsen protein that
transfers energy from the chlorosome to
the photosynthesis reaction centers and
there it was a protein unique to Green
sulfur bacteria a part of its ingenious
methods for harvesting sunlight
but where was the sunlight
[Music]
this is the weird part the bacteria
weren't actually harvesting sunlight
they were absorbing light from the
hydrothermal vent itself the scalding
temperatures of the vent produces
thermal radiation also known as infrared
light and the green silver bacteria's
chlorosomes were able to make enough use
of that light to carry out
photosynthesis they weren't like
thriving under these circumstances but
they were able to survive and that is no
small feat this actually wasn't the
first time scientists had found
photosynthetic bacteria in hydrothermal
vents but that previous find appeared to
only be getting extra energy to
supplement its primary chemosynthetic
source of food this was the first time
scientists had found a species entirely
dependent on photosynthesis at a
hydrothermal event a species whose
family is thought to survive only in
places with sun and it had turned up
deep in the ocean thanks to thousands of
pigment molecules that could take in
geothermal radiation in their paper the
scientists were quick to caution that
the discovery of green sulfur bacteria
in the hydrothermal vents doesn't
necessarily tell us much about the
evolution of life in those environments
the ecosystems in these types of places
are always shifting around and so we
can't Know Much from this one discovery
about how the presence of green sulfur
bacteria fits within the history of that
landscape and the life within it but
even if it can't tell us the entirety of
the areas past the discovery of green
sulfur bacteria in a hydrothermal vent
shows us just how broad nature can be in
applying the structures it creates
transforming an ancient process whose
requirements we thought we understood to
something entirely different
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us the names on the
screen right now they are names of our
patreon patrons people who help us
continue exploring this really marvelous
planet that we all get to inhabit
together if you want to become one of
them you can go to patreon.com journey
to micro and we very much will
appreciate it if you do it will allow us
to keep making more and better videos
like this one if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes James
Weiss you can check out jam and germs on
Instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's probably a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
[Music]